reales hear about celebrities calling
for gun control but then they star in
movies that prominently feature them
we've called them out for their
hypocrisy at this table over the years
but actor Ethan Hawke is offering some
refreshing honesty on the issue watch
when people are talking so much about
gun control in this country and that I
noticed recently like if you put in a
column every movie I ever did where I
carry a gun in every movie where I don't
and my salary like if I ask my father to
do the math yeah yeah I really think it
would be about 92 percent to 8 percent
sorry I thought that was gonna be Ethan
Hawke but it was Mike Baker that was
true about cigarettes too
yes are you good talking to me all right
we if Hollywood actually believed in
their causes there would be no guns at
all you could imagine and diehard like
Bruce McClane fighting those terrorists
with peace signs that's what they would
want so I have an idea I have an idea
they should apply gun control to movie
guns and the only way you could do this
is tax movies by amount of guns and by
the amount of bullets that they use per
movie now this week so I'm gonna I'm
gonna wonder Hollywood's gun control
activists and there are lots of him like
Alyssa Milano Jed Apatow whatnot
will they be okay for a gun control tax
on movies with guns tax the bullets ten
thousand dollars every time there's a
bullet a hundred thousand dollar per gun
would they do it somebody should
introduce that bill tomorrow okay I'm
full of ideas
Ethan Hawke is saying is that movies
where he there's guns he gets paid all
ninety two percent more than if he
didn't have a gun in a movie he'd would
get paid about eight percent of his
usual yeah Hollywood's made billions off
of guns all the big action movies from
the 80s and 90s whether it was the die
hard films or Schwarzenegger Chuck
Norris all these guys Rambo everybody
has a gun and they're all just mowing
down Quentin Tarantino kill him sure we
can get natural-born killers all that
stuff made a fortune for these studios
and then to come around and say that you
want to take away guns from law-abiding
Americans a little hypocritical I wanted
to bring something to your attention
here this happened yesterday there was a
school
shooting a nineteen-year-old brought a
gun right started opening fire into a
school in Illinois and an armed resource
officer shot um neutralize him didn't
kill him
and say Bennett Lovelace lives that
story was not covered anywhere in the
mainstream I was going to do it tomorrow
as a monologue as an exception to the
rule is the rule no it's not the system
not the bug all right all right but
here's the thing about this when people
complain about smoking in movies it had
an impact when people complain like it
do it no but they do it much less it did
have an impact and the same thing like
if you think about the how gays were
demonized in movies now it's not not an
issue more black actors especially up
for competition for leads and in big
movies it does make a difference and
then to say that yeah guns have made
movies for had made money for Hollywood
but in in a way it seems to me it's
encouraged the culture I go back to you
know I'm an old guy so I go back to
things like Gunsmoke John Wayne and all
that independent self-sufficient
American male but I wonder if at some
point it wouldn't be just as I say yeah
we can have a discussion about it it's
just because it's guns mate it doesn't
mean you can't discuss it what do you
think when you say guns encourage the
culture though what do you know-know
reflect reflect well I think they help
to shape the culture yeah in other words
if you're a guy and you say you know
what hey I'm gonna have a gun I'm a real
man and by the way I saw here that now
more parents say as long as the violence
is justified it like self-defense
they don't mind seeing the guns in the
moment sometimes people want when they
look at television in movies they just
want to be entertained and when I think
about this effort that could potentially
sanitize all of these things and oh
let's remove the violence and let's only
have it that's not what film and
television should be I mean some of my
favorite movies I love Liam Neeson I
love them and all the taken movies some
of these these movies and television
shows rely on that first storyline how
you gonna have a chase or you're you
know you're hunting down a killer and
you're gonna have no guns it's integral
to that and I I don't think I mean it's
like the same argument that people make
oh if you if you grow up playing violent
video games you're gonna be violent or
it just doesn't work your guest Greg's
tax plan what attach the ball I know I
want I want to see the gun control
actors four caliphs
we're in Hollywood except that plan I
think it would be amazing way to say
that happen but but it is true Jesse
that if you read as a youngster you do
become or don't like this narrative wait
wait can we work Russia into this let's
work Russia I don't want you to have a
heart attack so we are not going to do
that